Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Wie hat eigentlich Corona die Arbeit vor Ort bei der Nationalmannschaft verändert? Darüber wollen wir sprechen in diesem EM-Kurzpass mit Markus Bark, der ist freier Sportjournalist und unter anderem für die Sportschau unterwegs. Markus, sehr schön, dass du mal wieder Zeit für den Rasenfunk gefunden hast. Hi. Du bist ja inzwischen schon ein gern gesehener Gast. Was heißt inzwischen? Du warst immer ein gern gesehener Gast, aber die Hörerinnen und Hörer kennen dich bestimmt schon, weil wir auch schon öfter eigentlich auch dieses Gespräch hier geführt haben. Du begleitest die Nationalmannschaft, unter anderem für die Sportschau jetzt schon seit vielen Jahren. Und jetzt dachte ich, ich schnappe mir gleich deinen freien Abend nach der Gruppenphase und mache dir eine Freude, indem du jetzt mal nochmal über deinen Job reden darfst. Danke, dass du die Zeit dafür hast. Erzähl mal ein bisschen. Man kann ja auf sportschau.de dein EM-Tagebuch lesen. Wir hatten auch schon Noah Platschko hier im Rasenfunk. Der hat auch schon uns von den Bändchen erzählt, die man bekommt für positiv bzw. negative Testergebnisse, damit man überhaupt in die Nähe der Nationalmannschaft darf. Er hat uns auch von diesen Trackern erzählt, die losquäken, wenn man sich einem anderen, ebenfalls mit einem Tracker versehenen Journalist oder einer Journalistin näher nähert als anderthalb Meter. Wie ist denn das Arbeiten vor Ort? Ist das weird oder hat man sich schon schnell daran gewöhnt?
Da hat man sich tatsächlich daran gewöhnt. Ich war ja auch im Vorbereitungstrainingslager in Seefeld schon. Da galt es auch, dass man sich, ich glaube, das war DFB und ARD intern ein bisschen unterschiedlich. Ich musste mich auf jeden Fall auch da schon täglich testen. Da ging es aber sogar mit einem Selbsttest beim DFB an. Da ist es jetzt anders. Da muss man also am Medienzentrum und an unserem Compound wird das genannt. Das ist quasi das Containerdorf und Ü-Wagen und so weiter, wo dann gesendet, überspielt, geschnitten wird. Da muss man sich täglich testen, und zwar an der einen Station. Wenn man natürlich in München ist, zu den Spielen, muss man das dann am nächsten Tag nachweisen. Macht man das nicht? Braucht man wieder einen PCR-Test, den kann man auch da machen. Aber wenn man in Herzungen auch ist, kann man also nicht irgendwo in die Apotheke oder wohin gehen und schon gar keinen Selbsttest, sondern ist verpflichtet, das da zu machen. Das führte dann in den ersten Tagen morgens zu Staus, und dann hat sich das so ein bisschen eingependelt. Inzwischen ist das okay. Es ist zwar weiterhin eine recht lange Wartezeit auf das Bändchen, aber da mein Container recht nah ist, kann man dann schon mal den Rechner anschalten. Wie gesagt, man gewöhnt sich an alles und auch an die Apps, die man inzwischen auf dem Handy hat. Also zur Corona-Warn-App kommt mein Testergebnis, mein Laborergebnis, weil man halt manche nur mit diesen Apps abrufen bzw. dann nachweisen kann am Stadion. Dann muss man noch irgendwas von der UEFA ausfüllen.
Ja, das heißt ja aber auch, dass da ganz schön viele Daten und so weiter gesammelt werden. Ist denn das eigentlich alles geregelt, wie damit umgegangen wird von Seiten der UEFA, von Seiten des DFB und so weiter?
Das hatte ich ja tatsächlich auch im Tagebuch erwähnt, weil wir hatten ganz am Anfang, als wir zusammenkamen, eine Konferenz innerhalb der Redaktion. Und da sagte dann die Produktion, die uns hier super mit allen Infos versorgt und die Reisenplanung. Die sagte also, sie habe den DFB angefragt und mehrmals wurde versprochen worden, dass es die Informationen gibt. Und jetzt habe ich gesehen, ich glaube heute oder gestern, dass es die Informationen, wo es tatsächlich gibt, das sind sechs oder sieben DIN-A4-Seiten, die jetzt an einem Container hängen, klein gedruckt. Und du kannst dir vorstellen, was man mit solchen Sachen macht. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es da wirklich nur um die Nachverfolgung dann geht. Und wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise die Nummer 77 habe und die Nummer 68 standen, zehn Minuten neben mir und ich werde dann mal positiv getestet, dann ist die 68 dann, ich will überhaupt zehn Minuten reichen, vielleicht noch nicht, aber dann auch Kontakt Person eins. Und ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht. Wir haben auch nicht mehr darüber gesprochen. Es gibt auch viele Leute, die das Ding auf dem Schreibtisch legen oder dann versehentlich vergessen, weil ich glaube, dass mit den anderthalben Metern, das ist auch sehr positiv geschätzt. Ich glaube, das Ding fängt schon eher an zu brummen. Das ist natürlich schon nervig, auch wenn es sinnvoll ist. Aber man kennt das ja, wie man damit dann umgeht.
Wird denn eigentlich was Ähnliches dann auch bei den Nationalspielern eingesetzt? Weißt du da was?
Keine Ahnung. Das weiß ich nicht. Weil das ist natürlich schon ein Unterschied zu den vorherigen Turnieren. Wenn wir jetzt nicht auf der bekannten Position, die sieht man ja jetzt immer im Fernsehen, da die Nationalspieler zu Interviews kriegt, sondern in dem Camp, wo die wohnen, eigentlich ist es auch auf den Positionen, auf dem Gelände kein Unterschied, weil es darf nur kleinste Besetzung dahin. Sprich der Interviewer, Kameramann, Tonfrau, so ist das zumindest bei einem Team von uns, weil das das häufig macht, die Übersetzung. Und so wie früher, dass man dann als Hörfunk oder Online und Fernsehen dabei war, damit jeder sofort das hatte und die Infos, das geht jetzt in Corona-Zeiten nicht mehr. Und wie das im Camp aussieht, weiß ich nicht.
Wie hat sich denn ansonsten jetzt dann Corona ausgewirkt auf deine tägliche Arbeit? Also ich vermute, dass es weniger Poolgespräche geben wird. Das ist ansonsten ein ganz beliebtes Mittel, zumindest in den letzten Jahren gewesen, dass mehrere Spieler oder vielleicht sogar die ganze Mannschaft, je nachdem, wie man das gestaltet, für sogenannte Poolgespräche zur Verfügung stehen. Das heißt, es sind dann mehrere Medien, die in einer Gesprächsrunde eben die Möglichkeit haben, dann keinen exklusiven Zugang zu bekommen, aber in dieser Runde dann eben möglichst exklusiv. Gibt es denn sowas jetzt dann wahrscheinlich nicht mehr oder wie hat sich das verändert?
Also da weiß ich, ich habe ehrlich gesagt mit keinem Kollegen vom Print bislang darüber gesprochen, weil da sind wir ja so ein bisschen raus, weil ARD und ZDF als übertragene Sender und Rechteinhaber genauso wie Magenta ja dann die eins zu eins Interviews kriegen. Und ich muss ehrlich sagen, wenn ich mal in den Pressespiegel gucke, also ich finde da selten Interviews und mir ist noch keines aufgefallen, das in mehreren Zeitungen dann erschien. Was es in Seefeld gab, war ein digitaler Medientag. Da ging es also, die wurden dann in dieser Hütte, das war so eine Skihütte, die war umgebaut zum Medienzentrum. Da wurden die Spieler dann auf so eine Bank gesetzt. Fünf Minuten der, fünf Minuten der und dann wechselte das durch und acht, zehn Leute, weiß nicht genau, wie viele das waren, die konnten dann in verschiedenen Slots Fragen stellen. Aber eins zu eins mit mehreren Personen an einem Tisch, das gibt es trotz der nachgewiesenen negativen Tests nicht. Dafür ist der DFB und sind ja, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich auch andere Mannschaften sehr vorsichtig. Und das ist auch, glaube ich, von der UEFA vorgeschrieben.
Also mir ist nämlich auch aufgefallen, ich weiß es natürlich auch nicht genau, wie die Arbeitsbedingungen für die Print-KollegInnen sind, aber mir ist es eben auch aufgefallen, dass die Zitate, die man liest, und das ist ja eigentlich dann so das Kennzeichen dafür, ob direkte bilaterale Gespräche stattgefunden haben zwischen JournalistInnen und den Spielern, die gibt es eben eigentlich nicht mehr. Es gibt das, was man so mitbekommt aus den Interviews. Und dementsprechend habe ich nämlich auch das Gefühl, dass auch die Art und Weise, wie berichtet wird, sich ein bisschen gewandelt hat. Also, ich meine, der deutsche Sportjournalismus neigt natürlich auch immer dazu, Heldengeschichten zu erzählen, aber dass die Geschichte von Robin Gossens und seiner guten Leistung aus dem Spiel gegen Portugal, dass die auch wirklich noch bis zum Spiel gegen Ungarn eigentlich das Hauptthema ist in der Berichterstattung, das fand ich schon ehrlicherweise einigermaßen kurios. Und ich jetzt eben auch damit begründe, dass es eben, es gab sportlich gesehen und eben aus Spielerkreisen eigentlich kaum neue Themen, die man da hätte machen können.
Das würde ich auch so sagen, ohne dass ich da jetzt in Strichlisten geführt habe. Wir haben jetzt beispielsweise, also wir sind ja jetzt, das können wir ja denke ich mal sagen, Donnerstagabend und neun Uhr, halb zehn und vor einer halben Stunde oder so kam die Nachricht des DFB, dass auch der morgige Freitag medienfrei sei. Das heißt, es gibt noch nicht mal eine Pressekonferenz. Das heißt, wir sind dann nach dem Ungarn-Spiel zwei Tage ohne Training, ohne Pressekonferenz. Das ist schon hart, wenn man dann Beiträge und Berichte machen soll und keine frischen Bilder hat, keine frischen Töne. Und kann man natürlich sagen, man weiß ja eh, was die sagen, ja, aber mach mal Beiträge. Und noch viel schlimmer ist ja, wenn man dann als Zuschauer oder Zuschauerin sagen muss, ja, das wissen wir doch alle schon, das haben wir doch schon Dienstagabend alles gehört. Also das ist schon nicht optimal. Vielleicht gibt es ja morgen dann, das passiert auch manchmal, dass dann noch Gespräche geführt werden und gesagt werden, können wir nicht doch mit dem einen oder stell dich doch mal bitte dahin, mal gucken, wie es dann morgen ist. Aber zwei Tage ganz ohne, wundert mich eigentlich auch. Man hat natürlich immer noch die Möglichkeit als Trainer zu sagen, wir machen ein geheimes Training. Das kriegt man dann zwar auch irgendwo mit, aber dass es zwei Tage nichts gibt, ist schon bemerkenswert. Dass es am Tag nach dem Spiel nichts gibt, ist eigentlich, solange ich dabei bin.
Ja, genau, so hatte ich das auch immer abgespeichert. Ich habe dieses Jahr seltsamerweise, bzw. ich kann es begründen, aber ich habe noch keine einzige der Pressekonferenzen mitverfolgt, die vor Ort in Herzogen auch gegeben wurden. Bei vergangenen Turnieren habe ich mir das immer pflichtschuldig an jedem Tag, an dem es eine gab, reingezogen. Gleichzeitig, ehrlich gesagt, fliegen aber auch viel weniger Zitate an mir vorbei. Und ich schaffe es halt zeitlich derzeit gar nicht. Und habe halt auch die Gewissheit, durch die Arbeit von Leuten wie dir vor Ort, erfahre ich ja dann schon, wenn irgendwas passiert. Also kurz danach habe ich ja dann schon die wichtigsten Zitate. Muss ich mir jetzt auch immer gar nicht angucken. Aber nimmst du das denn auch entsprechend wahr, dass das generelle Interesse, vielleicht auch die Aufgeregtheit rund um die paar Zitate, die dir dann doch immer vom Laster fallen bei solchen PKs, dass sie ein bisschen zurückgegangen ist bei diesem Turnier?
Denke ich auch. Ja, es gibt ja, eigentlich gibt es kein aufregender Thema. Du hast gerade schon gesagt Robin Goossens und dann, wenn man sich das mal anguckt, das Instagram-Video von Robin Koch mit den Gitarre spielenden Nationalspielern, das schafft es ja auch, einen Tag quasi Thema zu bleiben, weil es ansonsten sehr ruhig ist. Ich muss sagen, im Gegensatz zu dir, habe ich es wenig geschafft, andere Spiele zu gucken. Dafür habe ich seit Seefeld, glaube ich, keine einzige Pressekonferenz verpasst. Und ich muss sagen, also ich fand, das kann natürlich, das fällt mir jetzt aber gerade auch erst auf, wo wir darüber sprechen und du das sagst, das könnte eine Diets dafür sein, dass es diese Gespräche nicht mehr gibt, weil nun fragt wirklich jeder bei Pressekonferenzen das, was er wissen will. Und ich fand, da gab es wirklich schon ein paar sehr gute Sachen, die auch Einblicke gaben, gab es dabei ganz gute Zitate, du wirst immer Spieler haben, die du als langweilig empfindest und die es dann vielleicht auswählen. Aber manchmal war ich auch tatsächlich schon überrascht, ja, wollen wir mal gucken, wenn es natürlich jetzt morgen auch keine gibt und dann Samstag erst, dann fangen die Spiele ja auch schon wieder an.
Da musst du dann schon anfangen, allen Nationalspielern auf Instagram zu folgen, damit du dann auch auf jeden Fall das nächste Gitarrenlagefeuer-Video nicht verpasst, weil das ja dann schon die wichtigste News ist fast an so einem Tag.
Da muss ich ehrlich sagen, sind wir sehr gut versorgt, weil wir haben natürlich aus Corona-Zeiten, es gibt ja Kommunikationsplattformen, da habe ich ja, also inzwischen gibt es die Gängen, aber es gibt auch einen, da hatte der DFB in Seefeld, das war glaube ich der Medientag, da musste ich mir eine App runterladen, dieses Programm, da hatte ich noch nie was von gehört. Und wir nutzen natürlich auch intern mit dem sogenannten Sport-Campus in Köln, das ist also da, wo alle Fäden zusammenlaufen für die Berechterstattung und da sitzen Social-Media-Abteilungen und wenn da sowas passiert, dann landet das relativ schnell darin. Ich muss sagen, ich habe hier auch Twitter-Konsum, also ist äußerst gering, weil die Zeit dafür auch dieses Jahr deutlich weniger ist als sonst. Wobei ich da ehrlich gesagt gar nicht weiß, woran das so liegt.
Ja gut, oder vielleicht ist es halt auch einfach dann die Sehnsucht nach Texten, nach Content, wie es ja Neudeutsch heißt, eben weil es eigentlich relativ ruhig ist und weil es eben weniger Geschichten drum herum gibt. Also ich habe da unter anderem auch Sebastian Wessling im Sportradio 360 gehört. Der hat zum Beispiel erzählt, naja, sonst hat man für Geschichten, von denen man schon wusste, die wird man in ein paar Tagen schreiben, konnte man schon mal rund um die Spiele sich O-Töne einholen. Also wenn du eben zum Beispiel ein Porträt schreiben willst, dann fragst du schon mal drei Mitspieler von Joshua Kimmich, was sie so über ihn denken und hast dann eben schon Zitate für zukünftige Texte. Und all das fällt eben jetzt gerade weg, war ja auch rund um die Spiele, was ja eigentlich immer der Zeitpunkt für Journalistinnen und Journalisten ist, in dem man den Protagonisten am nähesten kommt. Da ist halt der Zugang auch sehr eingeschränkt. Und wahrscheinlich kommt es dann zum Positiven dazu, dass man diese Fragen dann auf PKs stellt und es dann alle gleich hören. Aber natürlich aus Sicht derjenigen, die dann die Texte oder die Stücke dazu schreiben und produzieren, ist es natürlich wirklich noch schwieriger geworden, sich da auch irgendwie abzuheben, weil es war immer schon so, dass alle im selben Teich fischen, aber jetzt fehlen eigentlich auch so die ganzen Nebenflüsse, die man sonst noch so haben könnte, außer du hast den direkten Zugang zu irgendwelchen Spielern und die sind dann auch gewillt, dir irgendwelche Informationen zu geben. Das stelle ich mir schon schwierig vor.
Ja, und da hat sich auch ein bisschen was gewandelt, denn heutzutage wird es eigentlich so gemacht, dass man sagt, die Geschichte über XY, die machen wir jetzt vorher, obwohl wir keine Stimme von ihm haben, bevor er dann auf der PK sitzt und alle die Geschichte macht. Also diese Entwicklung, glaube ich zumindest, so rausgelesen zu haben, da wird kein großer Wert mehr drauf gelegt, dass man da auch dann tatsächlich eine Stimme zu hat. Ich finde das gar keine so schlechte Entwicklung, weil solche Sachen können das ja manchmal dann auch kaputt machen. Dann hängt man an diesen Zitaten und denkt, jetzt hat man sie endlich und muss die dann auch reinbringen. Also ich glaube, gute Geschichten funktionieren häufiger auch ohne Zitate. Und was natürlich der große Vorteil ist für mich als derjenige, der die Texte dann ja auch schreibt. Und wir haben ja dann ja auch die Möglichkeit, die Bewegbilder dann dazu zu stellen. Man kann das ja immer noch aktualisieren und ergänzen. Dann stellt man den Clip aus der Pressekonferenz dazu. Und ja, diese Möglichkeit hat der Print natürlich nicht. Von daher ist Online-Medien da auch schon einen großen Vorteil.
Wie würdest du denn sagen, hat sich das Interesse der Journalistinnen und Journalisten verändert? Sind jetzt weniger Kolleginnen vor Ort oder wie ist da die Lage?
Hat mich ehrlich gesagt gewundert, dass es hier bei der Europameisterschaft ähnlich voll wird, wie sonst auch. Das hatte ich mir schon gedacht. In Seefeld fand ich es enorm, dass da so viele waren. Die Ansage war eigentlich, dass beim Training das passiert, was normal ist, was jetzt hier in Herzogenaurach auch durchgezogen wird. Dass man also maximal eine Viertelstunde sieht in Seefeld, hat man mehr gesehen. Ich vermute auch, weil diese Bilder wurden ja auch häufig gezeigt. Da gab es ja diesen Wanderweg, wo dann die Zäune abgebaut wurden, weil du hattest eh die Chance, alles zu sehen, wenn du es wolltest. Da macht das dann auch keinen Sinn. Und bevor die Leute dann da klettern, und das war tatsächlich ziemlich steil an der Böschung, dann mache ich die Plakate lieber weg und lasse dann gucken. Aber trotzdem waren, also es waren Redaktionen da, die haben drei, vier, fünf Leute dahin geschickt, obwohl klar war, dass es die Chance auf ein 1 zu 1 persönliches Interview nahe null war und dass es digitale Pressekonferenzen gibt, ob man die jetzt von zu Hause macht oder vor Ort. Andererseits muss man auch sagen, wenn man, klar, wenn man das dann nicht so sich mit auskennt, mit der Branche, dann denkt man, okay, das ist völlig egal, ob man da zu Hause sitzt, aber du kriegst vor Ort immer mehr mit, immer. Ob das beim Bundesligaspiel ist, da siehst du vielleicht Feinheiten nicht so sehr und manche Sachen ärgerst du dich beim Text, gerade so beim Abendspiel, wenn du mit Schlusswiff sendest, ärgerst du dich, scheiße, das habe ich falsch gesehen, und denkst, hätte ich das am Monitor gesehen, am Stream, wäre es anders gewesen. Aber letztlich kriegst du immer mehr mit, wenn du vor Ort bist. Und ich finde es auch immer noch, dass es sich aus Anstandsgründen gehört, dann vor Ort zu sein. Und diesen Anstand verlieren inzwischen viele. Und würde ich jetzt bei der Europameisterschaft nicht sagen, aber so im normalen Alltagsgeschäft, wenn man da so sieht, wer angeblich aus irgendeiner europäischen Stadt über Europapokalspiele berichtet, aber am Schreibtisch in der Redaktion sitzt, das ist manchmal für mich dann als Freien auch ärgerlich, wenn man selber da hinfliegt und die natürlich auch die Kosten hat. Und die Redaktion, die man früher vielleicht noch beliefert hat, sagen, wir haben kein Geld und dann machen sie es vom Fernseher weg, um so, ja, letztlich sind es ja auch dann wirklich Peanuts zu sparen.
Ja, das ist natürlich ein spannendes Argument. Aber ich fand es jetzt auch interessant zu hören, dass das Interesse im Trainingslager so groß war. Und gleichzeitig hast du mit den Zäunen, die errichtet wurden und dann aber doch so abgehängt wurden, dass sich da niemand verletzt. Werder dann doch versucht, das Training zu begutachten, ja, ganz gut auch schon mal auf die Perspektive des DFB, auf das Ganze hingewiesen. Denn der steht ja weiter in diesem Zwiespalt. Also einerseits errichtet man solche Zäune irgendwo hoch oben auf einem Wanderweg, um ein Training abzuschotten. Auf der anderen Seite erkennt man dann aber auch sicherlich eben auch wegen der Gefahrenlage, aber auch generell, weil es auch glaube ich kein gutes Bild abgibt. Wenn jetzt schon mal Leute kommen, auch normale Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer, normale Fans, die das Training sehen wollen, dann sollten wir uns dafür dann vielleicht doch öffnen, denn das würde ja sonst viel konterkarieren, was man gerade versucht, nämlich sich den Fans zu öffnen. Und das betrifft ja auch indirekt die Medienarbeit. Wir haben das gesehen bei der Kaderbekanntgabe durch Joachim Löw. Ich habe, ehrlich gesagt, diese Pressekonferenz nicht durchgehalten. Da waren dann auch aus aller Herren Länder, also aus Deutschland, aber aus ganz vielen verschiedenen Regionen auch Fans zugeschaltet, die Fragen stellen durften. Und so schön dieses Signal ist, fand ich das ehrlicherweise gegenüber denjenigen, die das als Arbeitstermin haben, schwierig. Weil ich persönlich hatte die Freiheit, das einfach auszumachen. Wie bewertest du denn das Vorgehen des DFB in diesen Dingen?
Das sehe ich ganz genau so. Also wenn sie das machen wollen, können sie das gerne machen, sollen sie gerne machen, aber gesondert. Also wenn jetzt eine Pressekonferenz ist, das sagt ja schon das Wort. Inzwischen ist es ja eigentlich auch total veraltet, das Wort Pressekonferenz, das müsste eigentlich Medienkonferenz heißen. Aber davon mal abgesehen, das sind halt getrennte Sachen. Und das war ja ganz nett, der ältere Herr aus dem Seniorenheim, ich weiß nicht, was, Brandenburg oder so, das war auch ganz lustig. Aber dann soll man doch nicht diese Pressekonferenz benutzen, um jetzt die Aufmerksamkeit dafür zu gewinnen, dass man da jetzt irgendwie Fan-Nähe herstellt. Denn man muss auch mal beachten, da ist natürlich auch ein enormer Zeitdruck drauf auf solchen Sachen. Jeder will dann damit der Schnellste sein. Und wenn man dadurch, man bindet da vielleicht zwei Leute aus einer Redaktion, das hat doch bestimmt zwei Stunden gedauert, wenn ich mich recht entsinne.
Ja genau, die war ewig lang, also zwei Stunden.
Genau, das finde ich dann schon fragwürdig. Dann kann man ja sagen, wir fangen damit an, ihr könnt gerne euch schon dazuschalten, oder wir würden uns freuen, wenn ihr euch dazuschaltet, aber wir fangen dann erst um, keine Ahnung, meinetwegen um 13 Uhr mit der eigentlichen Pressekonferenz an. Und das finde ich, hat natürlich auch so ein bisschen Tradition beim DFB, vielleicht nicht mit der Fan näher, aber ich kann mich gut an Pressekonferenzen in Brasilien und auch in Frankreich erinnern. Da fing das mal an mit der Vorstellung einer neuen App eines gut bekannten Software-Herstellers, sagen wir mal.
Ja, ich erinnere mich.
Der auch Sponsor des Deutschen Fußballbundes ist.
Reimt sich auf eine Kölsche-Band.
Ja, genau. Und davon wussten wir vorher nichts. Also das war nicht angesagt, nicht angekündigt, sondern das wurde dann einfach gemacht. Und auch, ja, es gab auch mal eine, da stand plötzlich ein Produkt aus einer Sprühdose eines Herstellers, der mit dem noch aktuellen Bundestrainer wird. Ich denke, es müsste jeder darauf gekommen sein. Auf jedem Stuhl und naja. Ich weiß nicht, wer sich was davon verspricht. Aber das habe ich genauso gesehen wie du, da wurde viel Zeit vergeudet für Leute, die eigentlich arbeiten wollten und dann ja letztlich auch mussten. Und ja, hat das was gebracht, ich weiß nicht.
Also ich glaube ehrlich gesagt nicht, vor allem, weil das Ganze war halt aufgebaut wie eine Vorführung, also mit produziertem Trailer, der nochmal mit Blick hinter die Kulissen zeigt, wie jetzt Joachim Löw mit seinem Team darüber diskutiert, wie man eben diesen Kader zusammenstellt und dieses Turnierplan. Aber das ist ja alles Werbung und das ist auch legitime Werbung, die darf der DFB gerne machen. Und das ist ja auch durchaus interessant, dass da jetzt mal dann DFB-eigene Kameras mit dabei sein dürfen. Aber bei einem so wichtigen Termin, wie der Kaderbekanntgabe oder so potenziell wichtig, wie er sein kann. Es hängt natürlich auch immer ein bisschen davon ab, was bekannt gegeben wurde. Ich meine, in diesem Fall waren dann die wesentlichen Fragen dann eigentlich vorher schon geklärt. Aber dann ist es halt, finde ich, ein bisschen schwierig, das zu vermischen. Und ich frage mich halt immer noch, und kann mich das halt auch fragen, weil ich ja noch eine Distanz zum DFB habe im Gegensatz zu dir, der ja viel enger mit denen zusammenarbeitet. Was das darüber aussagt, wie sich das Verhältnis zwischen Journalistinnen und Journalisten und dem DFB verändert hat? Wie würdest du da, wie würde da deine Diagnose ausfallen?
Ich glaube, solche Sachen ändern da eigentlich nichts dran. Ich muss sagen, es gab in diesem Jahr, weil es ja auch wenig kritische, gab es überhaupt ein kritisches Thema? Also jetzt sagen wir, kritische Themen zum DFB natürlich, aber da meine ich jetzt nicht die Nationalmannschaft. Das muss man natürlich sagen, das spielt der DFB-Spitze natürlich schon in die Karten, das jetzt Europameisterschaft ist und die Nationalmannschaft spielt. Aber so bei der Nationalmannschaft gab es halt keine kritischen Themen, keine kritischen Nachfragen und dann ist das Verhältnis eigentlich in der Regel entspannt. Klar sind die Leute sauer, ist ja immer so, wenn man fragt, können wir den haben, können wir den haben und man kriegt ihn nicht. Und dann gibt es mal in den Abläufen Schwierigkeiten und so, das sind normale Reibungen, aber grundsätzlich, also ich habe noch von keiner Kollegin oder keinem Kollegen gehört, dass er Probleme hat und daran ändern auch solche Sachen mit der Pressekonferenz nicht. Und da weiß man auch wirklich nicht, dass das kann auch sein, dass das gar nicht diejenigen, die es dann letztlich durchgeführt haben, so geplant haben. Das ist ja auch fast untergegangen, einen bemerkenswerten Wechsel schon wieder in der Führung der Kommunikationsabteilung gegeben. Jan Bärle hat nach, ich glaube im Oktober hat sie angefangen, schon wieder hingeschmissen. Der Jens Kritner führt das jetzt, glaube ich, kommissarisch. Ich glaube aber nicht, dass er das letztlich dann auch als Chef der Abteilung übernehmen wird. Das war mal eine Stelle ausgeschrieben. Die ist jetzt zumindest öffentlich noch nicht besetzt. Ich bin mal gespannt, wie das weitergeht.
Welche Stelle genau ist das dann? Da muss ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt glänzen durch Unwissenheit. Also von welcher Stelle genau sprechen wir?
Die ausgeschrieben ist oder die durch Miriam Bärle frei geworden ist?
Die frei geworden ist und dann logischerweise auch hier.
und Kommunikations-Abteilungsleiterin, die Kommunikations-Chefin.
Genau, für den Verband dann und quasi der Unterschied. Ah, okay, alles klar. Okay, ja doch, jetzt habe ich es verstanden. Genau, und Jens Grittner ist ja dann Pressesprecher für die Nationalmannschaft. Das ist quasi der Unterschied. Deswegen übernimmt er jetzt den Verband auch mit. Und ist die ausgeschriebene Stelle jetzt dann eine andere als die der...
Und wie das genau aussehen sollte, weiß ich nicht. Und wie es jetzt genau aussehen wird, weiß ich auch nicht. Das habe ich aber, glaube ich, gemein mit Leuten auch im DFB, weil jetzt konzentriert sich natürlich auch alles erst mal hier auf das Turnier. Und ich glaube, die sind auch ziemlich froh, dass sie das Thema jetzt erst mal von der Backe haben. Also ich glaube das nicht nur, sondern man spricht natürlich auch so mal ab und zu, wenn was abgesprochen wird und kommt auf dieses und jenes Thema. Das ist natürlich auch ein Job, wo viele sagen, klar wird der gut bezahlt, aber den möchte ich auch nicht haben. Also ich würde sagen, nee, wäre sowieso nichts für mich. Ich könnte das auch nicht gut, das weiß ich auch. Aber das wäre auch in diesem High-Fish-Becken oder wie immer man das nennen mag, in der jetzigen Besetzung, glaube ich, wäre das nichts für mich. Wir hatten ja auch hier in den Pressekonferenzen häufig das Thema Stimmung und da muss man natürlich immer darauf oder man muss glauben, was die sagen, wenn man keine anderen Informationen hat. Und wir haben so ein, zwei Sachen hintenrum von Spielern oder auch aus deren Kreisen gehört. Und es ist schon glaubhaft, dass die Stimmung jetzt deutlich besser ist als 2018, weil das hing schon alles so ein bisschen über den ganzen Unternehmen da in Russland. Zum einen war Tutinki, zum anderen die Fotoaffäre. Und das ist jetzt besser. Letztlich ist es ja immer abhängig von Ergebnissen. Ist doch logisch im Fußball. Was wir hier in Herzungen-Aura und schon gar nicht, wenn man den ganzen Tag am Medienzentrum rumhängt, mitkriegen ist. Und deshalb würde ich dich jetzt mal fragen, wie ist denn so die Stimmung? Ja, gibt es eine EM-Stimmung? Gibt es eine Stimmung, eine gehobene Stimmung um die deutsche Mannschaft? Ich meine, England, Deutschland, in Wembley, da brauchen wir nicht lange drumrum zu reden. Das wären super Einschaltquoten. Und das interessiert natürlich auch. Aber ich glaube, ich habe hier ein Auto mit Fähnchen gesehen. Wenn du hier durch Herzungen-Aura fährst, du siehst halt die Bälle des Sponsors. Aber ansonsten finde ich, hier kriegt man herzlich wenig mit.
Ja, also für München würde ich das mit einer gewissen Klammer auch bestätigen. Vom EM-Auftakt hast du hier, der ja auch hier stattgefunden hat, gar nichts mitbekommen. Das war tatsächlich fast schon skurril, dass in deiner, in Anführungszeichen, Stadt, dass ein Spiel stattfindet und du bekommst es nicht mit. Hat natürlich auch mit dem niedrigeren Zuschaueraufkommen zu tun. Alles klar. Das hat sich allerdings dann zumindest hier in München mit dem Portugalspiel tatsächlich gewandelt. Also da hatte ich dann plötzlich hier Autokorso vor der Tür und musste den rausmuten aus meiner Schlusskonferenz zum Spiel. Das hat mich sehr überrascht. Es war allerdings kein langer und kein großer Autokorso, aber es wurde gehubt und es war kein Verkehrshuben, sondern es waren deutlich feiernde Menschen. Und ich hatte jetzt auch so ein bisschen den Eindruck, auch dann durch die Berichterstattung aus anderen Städten gewonnen, dass durch das Öffnen der Außengastronomie und das jetzt dann eben doch erste Public Viewings wieder möglich waren, es jetzt dann so langsam dann doch ein bisschen wieder anfing. Und ehrlicherweise muss ich sagen, wenn ich jetzt dann quasi hinter die Rasenfunkkulissen blicke, da war es so, dass im Grunde der Effekt eingetreten ist, den es sehr, sehr häufig gibt rund um die Nationalmannschaft. Vor den Turnieren wird dir von allen Seiten ungefragt erzählt, dass das Turnier total uninteressant ist und die Mannschaft sowieso doof und der Löw soll letztendlich weg. Und ich werde mir kein Spiel davon angucken. Und dann habe ich aber schon an den Download-Zahlen der EM-Vorschau gesehen. Da war der Hype genauso groß wie bei allen anderen Turnieren. Die Vorschau-Sendungen gehen immer total durch die Decke. Ich glaube, da waren wir jetzt bei 50.000 oder irgendwie so was ohne YouTube. Und damals waren es nochmal 8 oder irgendwie so. Also richtig, richtig, richtig viel. Und auch auf allen Länderspiel-Schlusskonferenzen zu den Deutschen sind die Downloads genau wie immer. Also da ist jetzt nicht mehr dazugekommen und das ist ehrlicherweise auch ein bisschen unter Bundesliganiveau. Das muss man schon auch dazusagen, aber das kann auch noch andere Gründe haben. Der Rasenfunk ist jetzt auch nicht, ist ja eher so ein Bundesligamedium in den Augen zumindest von manchen Menschen. Aber ich glaube schon, dass das Interesse da ist, aber nicht mehr die Bereitschaft zu feiern. Ich glaube aber ehrlicherweise auch, vielleicht bin ich da jetzt ein bisschen ungerecht, aber ich glaube, das hängt auch damit zusammen, weil man noch nicht weiß, ob es sich lohnt, mit dieser Mannschaft so voll mitzufiebern. Also sollte jetzt England 4 zu 1 besiegt werden im Achtelfinale, dann rechne ich damit, dass wir das dann doch auch deutlicher zu spüren bekommen. Aber ich glaube gerade sind die Leute noch so ein bisschen skeptisch und meiner Erfahrung nach ist es so, dass der Zug schon ein bisschen rollen muss Richtung Triumph, dass da Leute dann draufspringen.
Ja und ist das, ich habe jetzt auch in den letzten Tagen immer nur so die Entwicklung der Zahl, also der Inzidenzzahlen, Corona-technisch und Delta-Variante verfolgt. Aber ist das denn nicht auch so, dass in manchen Städten um 10 Uhr die Kneipen noch zumachen müssen? Weil dann kriegst du ja das Spätspiel, kannst du da gar nicht gucken. Also in Seefeld beispielsweise wollten wir natürlich auch das Champions League irgendwo gucken, Champions League Finale irgendwo zusammen gucken, aber ging ja dann nicht, weil um 10 Uhr müssen ja alle dicht machen und nur eine halbe Zeit macht ja auch keinen Sinn. Ist das jetzt bundesweit einheitlich geregelt?
Marcus, nein, also bundesweit einheitlich ist ja gar nicht geregelt, außer dass es kein Tempolimit auf der Autobahn gibt. Aber ansonsten wollen wir bundesweit. Also da bin ich jetzt natürlich auch der schlechtestmögliche Gesprächspartner, weil ich ja alle Spiele von hier verfolge, weil ich ja quasi auch parallel dazu arbeiten muss. Ich kann es dir ehrlicherweise nicht genau sagen, aber so aus dem Gastronomenbekanntenkreis, den ich habe, da habe ich zurückgemeldet bekommen in der ersten EM-Woche, dass es schon noch relativ verhalten alles ist, sogar auch bei den Spielen, die man eben sehen kann. Mein Gott, es ist halt immer noch Pandemie. Ich kann es ja auch nachvollziehen. Also das ist ja, es wirkt ja auch alles kontraintuitiv. Du siehst volle Stadien, du siehst wieder das, was man eigentlich so sehr herbeigesehnt hat, nämlich auch den Einfluss von Fans. Also das war ja bei Dänemark gegen Russland, das war ja fantastisch, das zu sehen. Und durchaus auch bei Ungarn gegen Frankreich, wenn man jetzt mal gewisse Dinge, die man gut oder schlecht finden kann, ausblendet. Aber grundsätzlich hast du gesehen, das hat eine Wirkung, wenn Zuschauer im Stadion sind, eben auf die Mannschaften. Ich glaube, dieses 1 zu 1 hatte auch mit den Zuschauern zu tun. Und gleichzeitig fühlt sich es aber sehr, sehr komisch an. Und ich könnte mir das noch nicht vorstellen, in dieser Kurve zu stehen, obwohl das eigentlich das Großartigste, was ich jetzt gerne tun würde. Und ich glaube, das überträgt sich auf alles, was mit der EM zu tun hat.
Ja, und da merkt man auch, wie unterschiedlich so die Völker sind. Der Kollege Holger Dahl vom Hörfunk, der war in Kopenhagen, bevor er nach München kam zum Portugal-Spiel. Und er sagte, du, ich bin da blöd angeguckt worden, als ich mit der Maske rumgelaufen bin. Da trägt keiner mehr Maske. Das ist vorbei da.
Ja, und jetzt gibt es drei positive Fälle, die im Stadion waren. Deswegen müssen sich zwei Blocke, nämlich 4.000 Menschen, einen PCR-Test unterziehen lassen in Kopenhagen.
Also ich habe gerade in einer WhatsApp-Gruppe von uns einen Tweet gesehen, kannte allerdings jetzt den Account nicht und weiß nicht, ob man das ernst nehmen kann. Aber ich denke schon, weil der Kollege, der das geschickt hat, der prüft sowas normalerweise und da hieß es, dass 100 Finnen, die vom Spiel in Sankt Petersburg nach Hause gekommen sind, positiv getestet wurden.
Ja, wunderbar. Ja, ich meine, sowas ist ja fast zu erwarten und dann trotzdem... Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, da wird in der Nachbetrachtung zu dieser EM noch viel auf uns zukommen. Da bin ich dann auch gespannt, was dann auch du berichten wirst, jetzt dann von diesem Achtelfinale in London, was ja so ein bisschen der Vorausgriff ist, auf die Halbfinale und Finalspiele, die da stattfinden werden, ja auch mit erhöhten Zuschauer aufkommen. Da bin ich wirklich sehr gespannt, was man da dann so berichtet bekommen wird.
Ich bin vor allen Dingen gespannt, ob ich dann vor Ort sein werde. Das ist alles noch nicht klar.
Wegen Quarantäneregeln?
Ja, auch wegen interner Bestimmung. Also die Regelung bei der Europamaßenschaft ist der WDR, der sogenannte Federführer, die Regelung ist, und das ist auch vernünftig, alles wird mit der MIN, wie soll man das sagen, also so wenig Leute wie nötig sind. Und da wir natürlich in London logischerweise auch schon Infrastruktur haben, dadurch, dass es ja auch Halbfinale und Finale da ist, kann das gut sein, dass ich da nicht reisen werde. Also Bucharest hätte ich wohl gemacht. Und wie es in Rom ist, da habe ich ehrlich gesagt, da haben wir noch nicht drüber gesprochen. Das ist so merkwürdig, darüber wurde jetzt noch nicht gesprochen. Zumindest habe ich davon nichts mitgekriegt. Wo wir jetzt gestern irgendwie, muss man ehrlich sagen, so ein bisschen in Schwimmen gekommen sind, ich hätte auch nicht dran gedacht, dass die es gegen Ungarn so wackelig nur hinkriegen. Ich hatte mit dem Thomas Bräuch ja auch telefoniert, der hatte die Ungarn gegen Frankreich gesehen und da sagte er, alles schön und gut, alles schön leidenschaftlich und so weiter, aber dies und dies und das haben sie in München halt nicht. Und er kann sich kein Szenario vorstellen. Also wir waren jetzt wirklich nicht darauf vorbereitet, dass das schon Schluss sein könnte. Aber das war 2018 gegen Südkorea, da war es auch keiner. Und von daher waren wir eigentlich, da hat die Frage, London oder Bucharest und nicht, ob man nach Hause fährt. Und jetzt haben wir dann ein paar Tage hier noch bekommen.
Ja, ein paar Tage hast du noch bekommen. Letzte Frage, Marcus, bevor ich dich in deinen wohlverdienten Feierabend entlasse. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie viele Turniere du schon begleitet hast, aber Campo Bahia, Vatutinki waren auf jeden Fall mit dabei. Wo würdest du denn dieses Erlebnis vor Ort in Herzogenaurach auf einer Unterhaltungsskala einordnen? Wie viel Spaß macht das im Vergleich zu den bisherigen Turnieren, die du so erlebt hast?
Ich weiß es noch nicht oft in der Altstadt, weil wir uns auch hier am Hotel häufiger dann abends treffen und das ist wirklich ganz nett. Hier ist so ein Park um 200, 300 Meter und es ist ein ganz einfacher Biergarten. Nur Bierzeltgarnitur, da gibt es Bier vom Fass und Wurst vom Grill. Der hat auch nicht immer auf, aber wenn man da mal hingeht, also in Herzogenaurach, kann man es absolut aushalten, was total fehlt, ist halt dieses Gefühl, dass es eine Europameisterschaft ist. Du fährst von Herzogenaurach über die Autobahn nach München und wieder zurück. Das ist jetzt letztlich ähnlich wie ein Bundesligaspiel, wo man ja auch dann mal zwei Stunden hinfährt und du kriegst halt überhaupt nichts mit. Du kriegst keine anderen Leute mit, du sprichst nicht mit Fans, das fällt auch aus. Das kommt sonst immer dazu, also mein erstes Turnier, zumindest für die Sportschau, war die Euro 2012, Polen, Ukraine und das war gerade so in der Ukraine, auch die Unterschiede in dem Land kennenzulernen, West-Ukraine, Ost-Ukraine. Das hat man ja dann auch leider jetzt erfahren müssen, welche Unterschiede es da auch gibt in dem Land. Das ist natürlich das, was es ausmacht und gut Herz und Aura kannte ich jetzt nicht, aber letztlich kenne ich den Menschenschlag und so und die sprechen alle Deutsch und die sprechen sogar...
Ja gut, also mittelfränkisch, also würde ich schon einschränken. Darf ich, weil ich ja aus der Gegend komme.
Dolle Dore schießen die alle, das ist ja richtig. Aber das fehlt absolut und deshalb habe ich schon gesagt, also Bukarest wäre schon geil, zumal das auch eine echt tolle Stadt ist. Ich war da schon einmal. Hätte ich halt gerne gemacht, damit man einmal so das Gefühl hat, ja, das ist jetzt wirklich so ein großes Turnier, wie es sonst auch war, wo man dann auch mal reist und andere Leute, andere Fans sieht und so. Aber ja, wenn es da nicht wird, dann ist es halt so. Ich hoffe und bin auch relativ zuversichtlich, dass wir mitbegehen der neuen Bundesliga-Saison. Dann so halbwegs wieder in den normalen Modus kommen, dass wieder Amateur-Fußball gespielt wird und dann wieder auf die Plätze kamen. Also wenn mir einer die Gewissheit gibt, dann unterschreibe ich gerne, dass ich von Herzungen auch hier meint wegen auch bis zum Ende berichte, ohne irgendwo noch in einem anderen Stadion zu sein.
Ach, das ist doch ein wunderbares Schlusswort. Marcus, ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank. Liebe Leute da draußen, folgt ihm auf Twitter Artus69 heißt er da. Es lohnt sich immer, Marcus zu folgen. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank, Marcus Bark. Schön, dass du hier im Rasenfunk warst und schönen Feierabend jetzt dann. Du auch, bis bald und euch auch eine gute Zeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Der Rasenfunk ist allein Hörerinnen und Hörer finanziert. Bitte unterstützt uns auf rasenfunk.de/supporterscluberfahrtihr, wie das geht und morgen hören wir uns wieder. Es wird auch morgen einen weiteren EM-Kurzpass geben zu einem allgemeineren Thema, zu dieser Europameisterschaft und dann geht's ja weiter mit dem Achtelfinale. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund, passt auf euch auf. Bis bald hier im Rasenfunk.